hey guys welcome back to a brand new
video we're back on foreigner again and
yeah somes a little bit screwed up with
foreigner as of recent uh the characters
now have lightsabers I was a little bit
confused I'll explain in a second how
this even came up once we get into the
match but yeah lightsabers are now on
for honor cuz it is May 4th it's about
12:30 in the morning as I'm making this
so it's basically may the 4th be with
you in terms of referencing to Star Wars
so yeah like to do enjoy guys subscribe
if you're new I covered the
informational site or foreigner that
being balanced changes here are updates
patch notes and leaks if we want to be
kept up to date with everything
happening within the world before honor
that we stay subscribe to the channel my
Twitter and discord up in the
description down below we're gonna be
using the hito kiri a little bit showing
off the little red that you may or may
not have maybe you have some blue
lightsaber not really sure well with
that let's get started I and we're
finally in the game so I got oh I got
the red color Oh I'm fierce now I like
that [ __ ] that's cool I like that so
yeah as you could probably tell I'm on
PC right now as the few of the view and
the fact that I'm a rep for overall the
only I really wish I could have played
on the Xbox account you know my rep 127
or whatever it is but the problem is
that like al gato is screwing up al gato
is the program that I use honest dodged
an elgato is the program that I used to
record all my gameplay and for some odd
reason it won't show game audio and
seeing as this has to do with a lot of
you know lightsaber sounds and stuff I
wanted everyone in the video to hit to
hear that so I wasn't able to record it
which really sucks I saw him on PC right
now so really not a big issue I've been
playing a little bit of PC a lot more
really enjoying the extra 30 frames I'm
getting here playing a lot of heat so
kiri but yeah I mean honestly updates
gonna be updates really cool here it
doesn't even require any gigabytes to
install or anything it was more hot
fixed then I don't think this is gonna
stay very long probably just the fourth
so if it's like for Saturday or notes
Saturday would be actually the fourth so
I believe if it's like May 5th so I
believe Sunday here - if it's Sunday and
like America are probably Monday and if
you're Australian and stuff like that
it's most likely gone I'm assume
I actually don't know how long this will
stay probably not too long I would
assume because it doesn't really make
sense to have anything on the fifth well
right now clapping right now throughout
this Oh double kill do can I get a team
wipe please can we keep going with this
team wipe he should have been gone I've
carried him oh I'm dead now oh I'm alive
I'm alive
oh that's risky risky moves let's go
awesome Wow it's a team wipe for me Wow
the the only reason that I'm even
recording this right now cuz I wasn't
even planning on playing for honor
tonight I played a lot this afternoon
but I was just gonna get off watching
YouTube and chill but I was talking with
infinite and talent some other foreign
recruiters you might know we were just
playing at infinity tournament every
tournament as already is gonna be
happening tomorrow I'm gonna be co
commentating it on Sunday so I'll leave
a link in the community tab and discord
and stuff so that people can understand
it and know where that when the
tournament is and stuff yeah we were
just talking to discord call and all of
a sudden town was talking about how
there's lightsaber noises and stuff and
I thought he was bullshitting it could
have been a bug but I guess it's
actually legit because I checked reddit
and everyone's raving about this so you
know I had to make a video on it well
let's follow up oh i don't why gar broke
that was stupid I was really dumb
got to live a little bit more that was
really dumb gonna get this new show damn
let's try I'm still getting a little bit
used to playing soccer oh right now you
know it's been a couple days I think
this is the second day released so she's
a little bit new and it could be third
depending on when you're watching this
this is technically Saturday morning in
a way or Friday night yeah I mean she's
solid characters still getting used to
work she's gonna I feel she's gonna be
really nice in a four V force I'm not
really sure about duels but just playing
her a lot I think that she's a really
nice character to be honest she looks
great I'm not
big on the armor though I'm more big on
the honor weapons or weapons probably I
probably have a lot more customization
in my opinion I feel like they worked on
the weapon a lot more than the armor but
that's just me
I still think both of her both of her
you know outfit and weapon and stuff
look great but I personally have a
liking for the weapon more or as a VP I
was really always I was really cool
about the armor so it's a little bit
different this time go for the light I
had fate he saw it in absolutely
destroyed are now but it's a light
attack dodged a little early I'm trash
I'm a [ __ ] bot
this law burgers gonna kill me I'm gonna
be mad aren't even has a lightsaber
Ching or whatever it's called when you
connect with them that's cool
can't open him up man I'm mad I'm
definitely gonna die now that he's got
oh wait no we're going for the one hit
bop easy
this fourth beat is so goddamn clean I
feel like well she does have fear itself
as a tier 4 feet which is obviously
really nice to have especially when
you're in a competitive setting your
fear itself is just really nice for
lowering that defense when needed
depending you know if it's a big
teamfight but just using this tier for
feet is just really satisfying I think
it's more just because of how long it
takes to activate and the fact that it's
so long but yet there's the you know
then there's the chance that you land it
and you get rewarded with a one shot I
think that's amazing
who's next to me loggers on me again
okay heavy heavy heavy light I must have
been go for a sweep here
well that's Dodge don't be throwing
heavies out like that brother I mean I'm
not doing too bad nine and one clapping
right now our team's losing so I'm gonna
have to go to the objective help it out
a little bit heavy sorry sorry Sakura
heavy
I'm messing her up bad heavy heavy
infinite heavy chain is stupid
it's really fun to use I feel like it's
just gonna become irrelevant after a
week because it's just so easy it's it's
just like constant light it attacks
you'll eventually land one that's why I
don't like doing it like two or three
lights in a row for gladiator because
that's just an easy parry sinan goes
with a heavy one indy got me instantly
one two three
he's I mean he's pretty solid too
blocking it's not hard to block a heavy
of course but he's he's got it nailed
down
if he can be distracted for like two
seconds like right here bye-bye
thank you I'll take your health can't
say help me I was trying to go for that
guard break I really like how soccer has
variable heavy timings the chance to
just you can either buffer the heavy the
straight up just heavy you can delay it
a little bit I know or you can go to the
unblockable I like how there's a lot of
timings with that really helps boost er
up in tier and just makes her a
formidable foe and she didn't have this
she'd probably be really garbage wall
burned with this blue looking real clean
I like that I really like the lightsaber
sound when you connect together when you
block I think that's probably my
favorite part we're making a comeback
we're probably gonna start losing soon
and we lost [ __ ] well [ __ ] I thought we
had that win oh well anyway guys that's
probably gonna be the end of this video
I just want to show a really quick you
know with Dominion gameplay of the
lightsabers I was really surprised
actually cuz my team had the lightsabers
but the other team didn't except the law
breaker I don't really know what was
going on with that cuz I played a game
before this just a quick one when I was
testing my Xbox account and everybody
had lightsabers they had greens reds
blues and all that stuff so I was really
confused like what the hell was going on
there yeah I mean I guess it's it's
pretty cool I think it's only gonna be
here for a day probably just May 4th so
if you have the chance I would highly
recommend you going take this chance to
play a couple games just for fun might
as well yeah I like TV if you do enjoy
guys subscribe if you're new let me know
your thoughts on the wall on the
lightsabers for May 4th and all that
stuff I think it's pretty cool
subscribe if you're new I've covered the
informational site a foreigner that
being balanced changes here or updates
patch notes and leaks we want to be
catch though today with everything
happening within the world of foreigner
I never miss out an update that we
subscribe to the channel okay that guys
my two most recent videos gonna be
popping up on screen so if you guys want
to check those out we covered a lot of
stuff regarding Sakura and then some new
stuff coming within the season like
tipos emotes and other cool things like
that so if you want to check those out
to be highly appreciated
my Twitter and discord to be in the
description down below enjoyed the
lightsabers may the force be with you
and peace out guys take care
[Music]